COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I help some cloudy file
servers clear their performance
thoughts.
Will they see clearly
once the fog is gone?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Nimbusdisk is a Cloud based
file system company who
is having some trouble
with their persistent disk
performance.
They tried all the
usual suggestions
like analyzing disk
size and CPU count,
but still weren't seeing
the performance they wanted.
And while digging
around for other things
they might be able
to try, I actually
stumbled into this little gem.
It says, the default block
size on volumes is 4K.
For throughput oriented
workloads, values of 256k
are recommended.
Now, unbeknownst to me,
this single sentence
was exactly what was
causing the Nimbusdisk woes.
So generally speaking, when
it comes to disk operations
a block is the
smallest unit of data
that is read during
an I/O operation.
So if you're trying
to read 5 bytes
and your block
size is 512 bytes,
the entire 512 bytes
will be read from disk,
even though your application
will only use 5 bytes from it.
So with this in mind,
it's important to observe
the following formula with
respect to disk performance.
Now, how this evens out is that
the IOPS and the block size
tend to have an inverse
relationship to each other.
As block size
increases, it takes
longer to read a
single block and thus
the number of IOPS decreases.
Inversely, small block
size yields higher IOPS.
To figure out how GCP's
persistent disks behave
as the block size changed I
set up a simple 32 core machine
with a 1 terabyte standard
persistent disk attached to it
and tested the performance
against block sizes.
What we see, expectedly,
is that as the window
size grows our IOPS get lower
and our throughput gets higher.
Likewise, we can
do the same test
for an SSD persistent disk.
And we see a similar
reduction in IOPS
as block size increases.
But, by the way, that hard
cap you see for throughput
at 16k window size is
actually a function
of the testing
config I was using.
By increasing our PD SSD
side, or moving to 64 cores,
we should be able to
remove that limit.
Now here's the important part.
By default, GCP's
persistent disks
use a block size of 4k which
is perfect for higher IOPS
workloads like
relational databases.
Nimbusdisk, however,
was much more concerned
with throughput,
which meant they
wanted to be on the other
side of the block size window.
With a simple config change to
move to a 1 megabyte blocksize,
their perf increased about 30x.
Not bad for a simple
command line flag.
If you'd like to know
more about this problem,
check out the article listed
in the description below.
And don't forget to check
out the rest of the Cloud
Performance Atlas
content because when
it comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]